Pete Davies author of American Road
what's your book about the book is about
the first transcontinental motor train
which went from Washington DC to San
Francisco in 1919 really though it's
three stories for the price of one the
general background is the dawn of the
motor age and the explosive expansion of
the automobile industry in the first two
decades of the 20th century more
specifically you have the story of the
Lincoln Highway which is the first
transcontinental Road in the USA and
then the convoy which this book tells
the story of crystallised way of the
need for that road had arisen and they
were trying to get from Washington DC to
San Francisco they had no certain idea
that they actually could get there but
they were trying to get there and prove
why that the federal government needed
to get into the road building business
and crystallizing in the process that
really pivotal moment in the United
States history when the American people
were motorized if you like to put it
that way you say you've first learned
about this when you're reading the prize
by Daniel Yergin a book about all did
you do this that would have been in late
2000 and I was interested in the history
of the oil industry and yoginis book is
a magisterial account of that business
and by chance I mean a lot of the best
stories you stumbled on them by chance
and the first three paragraphs of
chapter 11 so just live literally a
matter of a few hundred words he talked
about a young man named wide the
Eisenhower crossing the country with
this convoy and it just caught the
imagination
I wondered if anybody had looked into it
and to be frank was astonished when I
found out that no one had told this
story because the 49ers the Pioneer
Trail the Transcontinental Railroad
everybody has a consciousness of those
two things it seems to me that I would
have thought everybody would have known
about the First Transcontinental Road as
well because that's the next chapter in
the story but I emailed a whole lot of
my friends in the States
and said have you heard of this and
university they all said no and I could
not believe that so
Jurgen talked about it being a pivotal
moment and I went down to the British
Library and started researching it and
it just struck me as absolutely
fascinating it's fascinating the fact
that you have that convoy to give you a
narrative and it is an epic story it's
an amazing story it's incredible that
they got across and only lost six
vehicles along the way it's actually
incredible that they got across without
anybody dying the fact that that
happened and the huge import of the
event was interesting to me but doubly
interesting because it had just fallen
off the map of history and that seemed
bizarre that people should not know
about this so we can get right into
their thick of things we've got some
video shot by the army I had the Signal
Corps shot listen it was shown on
theatres all along the route and I would
love to have been in those theaters to
see the reaction of people to what they
were seeing three and a quarter million
people were along the route of this
crumble as it went across the country
1919 who are they all military not all
almost exclusively that the personnel of
the convoy was I believe about
thirty-seven offices and I think 258
enlisted men but alongside of them were
journalists and representatives of the
motor industry because the mantra
industry were Foursquare behind this it
was really their idea it was Detroit's
idea and Detroit went to the Motor
Transport core which was a new arm of
the military that had been formed up
during World War one and said look we
you know we have all these trucks we
have this need for roads let's do this
together started July 7th 1919 from the
White House yep from the White House on
an end how long did it take took them 62
days and I think the last day was
September 6th at the Presidio in San
Francisco did they stop every night
yep they stopped every night they had a
route out of schedule they weren't
always able to stick to it because as
you can see their road conditions
weren't always too good they were I
think six days late as against the ideal
schedule that was laid out from where
they set off road conditions once they
got past
the Mississippi really they were lucky
and I were because it didn't rain if it
had rained in eyewear they would have
been employing gumbo up to the hubs all
the way across instead they were in
clouds of choking dust we're talking
give or take three thousand two hundred
and fifty miles of which less than a
third is paved by the time you get into
western Nebraska Wyoming Utah Nevada all
there was there was two wheel tracks
through the sagebrush showing a photo
earlier and the man on the right is
Dwight Eisenhower how old was he in this
place he was 28 and he was a lieutenant
colonel which was a temporary honor was
a temporary promotion put it in wartime
and he was about to be demoted back to
his standing rank captain right above
that it's a photo that has a famous name
in it Harvey Firestone have you first
done he was he sent a truck alongside
the convoy Dwight Eisenhower there on
the right 265 other six-foot oh yeah the
good-looking blonde that was at Harvey
fast stones Manor ha Bell manner it was
called it was outside a little town
called Columbiana in Northeast Ohio and
the tire magnates were important it
wasn't just Detroit it was also at Crum
it was very big on this Frank Seiberling
who was the president of Goodyear Tire
and Rubber was a big shaker and mover in
this exercise as well the motor ad was
dawning and they wanted to make sure
that the Army was running on the rubber
that they sold who paid for this trip oh
you know it's not me paid for it but I
think they had some deals I think they
had Standard Oil supplying them with gas
here and there but no it was an Army
exit exercise it was a war departments
exercise but no book has ever been
written about this no which as I say I
find amazing but also very fortunate for
me there is a very nice book called the
Lincoln Highway main street across
America that was published in 1988 I
know if they're called Drake Hawkinson
that is a very nice account of the road
and of the guys who created the idea of
it and promoted it it's got nice
illustrations it's admirably clear it's
got a deft wit about it it's a nice book
but that is 14 years ago and as I say it
why has no one addressed this possibly
because roads are mutable things
when you're looking at the first
transcontinental railroad you vote
you've only got the truck and the trains
got to go on it but no point of that the
car is it's it's a personal liberation
and once people are starting to drive in
cars well it can go off here they can go
off there and maybe because of that may
be because the Lincoln Highway only
survived under that name until the mid
20s and then the federal government
stepped in and started giving roads
numbers instead of names
it just has slipped the memory slip the
national memory the connection between
Dwight Eisenhower and the interstate
highway system in the United States
that's a really important issue it would
be very simplistic to say that because
he went across the continent in 1919 in
1956 he starts saying let's have
interstates and science the
authorization he himself said that the
1919 convoy gave him the idea that
America needed good two-lane highways
which was adequate for the traffic at
the time in Germany during World War Two
he saw the autobahns that Hitler had
built and that was more of a spur to the
creation of the interstate system
nonetheless because he'd done that trip
in 1919 he never forgot it and one of
the officers that was with him on the
trip when he retired from the motor
industry in Detroit his colleagues wrote
to President Eisenhower and said would
you care to acknowledge this man's
career now that he's retiring and he
wrote him a really nice letter really
nice letter saying you know you may
recall some years ago we went on a
little journey come back to the
beginning of this you were reading the
prize again about what month of mm what
October maybe October 2000 okay what did
you do then well as I said went to the
British Library and looked into it and
became fascinated with how much it told
about that time about the change the
transformation and society that the way
Americans took to the automobile and at
that point you have the evolution of the
modern societies you're a living where
I'm living I live in West Yorkshire in
northern England and how far is that
from London 200 miles north of London so
you go the British Library in London
uh-huh
and then when do you get to the United
States well I've been to the United
States more times than I can count
what did you come on that trip well I
did I did the background research and
then I first of all I went to the
Eisenhower Center in Abilene Kansas
because there's a wealth of material
there connected to the trip
Mike's own reports on it because he went
along as an observer for the tank corps
but it also reports by many of the other
officers involved and crucially for the
practical nuts and bolts of the story
the most junior officer on the trip was
a guy called Elwell Jackson who was a
first lieutenant from Philadelphia and
he was a reserve reserve officer and he
was a member of the American Society of
Mechanical Engineers and he went along
and wrote telegrams that went back to
Washington every day reporting on their
progress where they stopped how they
fared how the vehicles worked and he was
a meticulous extraordinarily diligent
reckoner of snapped fan belts and
clogged carburetors and with that in
hand you have a daily record of
everything that they went through the
convoy commander Colonel Charles mcclee
are also sent back telegrams which I
found in the National Archives in
Washington so you have two daily records
there but you drove this trip oh yeah
yeah so I did the Abilene the Eisenhower
Center in Abilene and then there are
some marvelous collections in Ann Arbor
Michigan where I was able to get a lot
of historical background research done
and then on I think it was a 7th of
April 2001
I bought a pea green 1995 Chevy Caprice
for $2,000 where jimmies autos on New
York Avenue Northwest right here uh-huh
he said I could buy a more expensive car
but if all I wanted to do was get to San
Francisco then in that car would get me
there and it did it did 6,000 miles and
all it asked for was one quart of oil
all the way now when you do something
like that is that that your expense well
you have a contract and you're out there
spending that money yes but I mean is
that all part of the
I'm spending my money to get the story
and I mean without wanting to sound
frivolous about it have fun because
anybody that's touch with wanderlust has
a list of journeys they want to make in
their life and without ranking them in
any order of preference the top five for
me would be to go to the lost city of
Machu Picchu in the Peruvian Andes to go
down the Nile and see the wonders of
ancient Egypt to go on safari in East
Africa and see the wildlife because I'm
English to go on a cricket tour of the
Indian subcontinent and that fabulous
historic journey from East Coast to West
in the United States what I'd done all
the other fall but I hadn't done it lent
it the Pacific and here was an
opportunity for me to do something I'd
always wanted to do with you know
they're obviously rather legitimate
objective of producing a decent book
about it in the end and it's not
interesting to me to write a story that
has the word I in it all the time you
know that he was this fabulous existing
story that had not been told and that
was what I wanted to do to recreate
their journey and because I'd found all
that background material in Kansas and
Michigan I was able to travel as nearly
as is possible on the same route that
they took in 1919 stop every place that
they stopped go into the local libraries
and I would really like to stress I did
not meet one single unhelpful librarian
in the United States of America and what
a treat that was made it easy made it a
lot easier did you stop for the same
length of time in each of these town no
it gets harder as you get further west
in the East the town was there then the
towns there now you get out into Wyoming
you know Utah and Nevada there there are
places that they stopped that just not
on the map anymore
and even when they were on the map there
wasn't a library there or a newspaper so
out west you have to rely more on state
archives
but they do have all the material if you
know what I look I know if you don't
know where to look the librarians are
very helpful and find it for you go back
to though you're for trips that you have
wonder lust that you've seen you know
you're at the end of your five trip did
you write any books off of it any others
in different ways yeah I did not she
Picchu when I was 25 and that was that
was a time when I was working on my
first novel and I was I didn't have a
contract for it I'd sold the novel on
the first draft and the publisher in
London at that time had said well you
can have five hundred pounds and you can
have fifteen hundred pounds when you
come back with the completed second
draft and at that time a return ticket
from London to Lima was 499 so I spent
the 500 on a return ticket to labor and
they got very anxious and said well you
know you're supposed to be finishing the
second draft of your novel what are you
doing going to pro and I said I'm taking
a typewriter with me and while I'm there
I'll check out Machu Picchu and assorted
other things so I did the East African
experience the Nile was my honeymoon um
so I didn't write a book about that the
East African experience did end up in
fiction or I've been there a couple of
times so I guess I've taken that one off
more than once
what do you get their interest in doing
all of us well I've wanted to be a
writer since I was seven my father was
in the Royal Navy and as a child in the
60s we grew up with
obviously bookshelves full of books of
military and specifically naval history
and when I was seven I had a bad dream
about the sinking of HMS hood by the
Bismarck during World War Two in the
North Atlantic and the next day in a
maths class I wrote it down because I
wasn't very good at maths and I was
bored and I was sitting in the back and
I'd had this intense vivid dream and of
course I was discovered and teacher took
this stuff away from me and told me to
concentrate and called me up at the end
of the class and
I was expecting to get tipped off and
she did you know should be concentrating
but mind you this is very good and they
got published in the school magazine
which was nice
and you can fail that was the stuff my
career I I just always knew that I
wanted to write how many books have you
written this is number eleven that's
published but I have actually written a
couple more than that um I wrote my
first novel when I was 19
between the first and second years of my
time at Oxford and it's unutterably
dreadful I wrote my second novel when I
was 22 it's not so bad but it's still
pretty dreadful and then I got a job
writing copy an advertising agency in
which I did for two and a half years and
then I wrote my third novel which is the
first proper one and this is the one
that got published the one that got
finished in Peru and the difference is
night and day and the training that I
had writing ads for two and a half years
was just extraordinary useful it made me
a much much better writer it made me
much more economical and I shall always
be glad of that
April 7th 2001 you buy the pea green
Chevrolet Caprice do you have anybody
with you on this trip no and if I had
have had anybody with me they would very
rapidly have left because there had been
very bored because I'm having a great
time I'm driving down the road from one
little turn to the next following the
path of the 1919 convoy but every place
I stopped I'm looking for material on
them it would not have been fun to be in
the passenger seat because what would
you've seen you just seen the inside of
a lot of libraries in the back and in
the front you have the actual map
actually where it's the wrong end on
this map at the moment I want to go over
at the beginning this is Washington DC
where it starts what is and you go right
through the states of Ohio Indiana
Illinois Iowa Nebraska Wyoming Utah
Nevada California what what road is
there now
it's bits and pieces a lot of it is us
30 there's a very nice passage in in I
think mid to western Nebraska where you
can see three generations of industrial
progress right alongside each other
you have the railroad with those
wonderful huge Central Pacific Union
Pacific freight trains hundred cars long
tying along beside you and you have the
interstate and between them you have the
original US 30 and that's yeah it's the
kind of thing that we just take for
granted you know trains railroads cars
part of life but to begin with none of
that was out there and and out there you
can see the three things right next to
each other yeah us 30 a lot of the way
in west central utah there's 180 mile
stretch of the original 1913 route of
the Lincoln Highway that's still not
paved today and I don't think it'll ever
be paved and that's a particularly
interesting section of the story the
controversy in Utah about whether to go
across 40-plus miles of Salt Flats on
the northern route to Wendover which the
interstate does now do and the
proponents of that route won that
argument or they wanted the Lincoln
Highway guys who promoted it the people
in Detroit wanted to take a more
southerly route that followed the Pony
Express in the Overland Trail there were
arguments for both routes in a way today
I'd be thankful that Wendover run
Wendover won because it means you can do
that 180 miles of dirt trail through the
desert and it is fabulously beautiful
you say in there there was a day that
you drove eight hours it was the most
beautiful yeah in my experience the only
landscape that's of a parallel grandeur
and isolation and just magnificence
would be in Namibia in Southwest Africa
heart-stoppingly gorgeous and and
because the mounted chains run
north-south what you're doing is you're
cresting one rugged difficult pass after
another dropping down into one huge arid
Valley after another and you're on your
own you know this is a drive where you
take extra gas water food because if you
do break down you may be there for a
while
but that didn't worry me in the least
because it was so wonderful to be out
there it's so beautiful but then even
when you're on the on the pavement going
through central Nevada I mean that's
perspective spectacularly beautiful as
well again it's one of the great things
I live on a small cramped island it's
England its Great Britain yes and to be
in western Nebraska that imperceptible
climb up from Omaha across 500 miles in
Nebraska and to realize as you get into
the high plains there that you are
higher above sea level than any point in
the entire British Isles and you're just
in this sagebrush and prairie plain high
plain wonderful gorgeous who is this man
right here Henry joy he's one of my
heroes in this story he was the son of a
railroad magnate in Detroit he's pre
gasoline Society he had a pile of money
he need never have lifted a finger in
his life to do anything more than buy
another trash of stocks and shares
what's he sitting in here
that's an 1899 original Packard model a
and what joy did was well the story's
apocryphal but he was with his
brother-in-law
Truman handy Newberry in New York then
walking down the street and there's a
guy there salesman with two of these
newfangled automobiles on the street
this is 1899 and the guy says you know
do you want to look at the cars and
they're busy they say no fire engine
shoots past in the salesman obviously a
sharp witted fellow says you know jump
in I'll take you to the fire so they do
and they like the vehicle so they
bye-bye thumb and these were original
1899
that joy board another model when he
heard the next one was coming and it was
such a story at the time that if the
prominent citizen because only the
wealthy could afford automobiles they
know they cost you know unimaginable
money two and a half thousand dollars
for a luxury car it was a story if a
prominent citizen ordered a car so it
appeared in the local newspapers you
know automobile which Harry joy has
ordered I think about November 2 1983
your car to actually arrive again it's a
story in the papers there enjoys new car
has arrived it's a Blue Devil I think
was the headline and joy liked the car
so much that he drove it back to the
plant in Warren Ohio where it had been
built and he bought the company and he
relocated the company to Detroit and he
put in I think twenty five thousand
dollars of his own money at the
beginning and realized that this would
not be remotely enough so he went around
his very gilded circle of friends at the
height of Detroit Society and put five
hundred thousand dollars together and
put together a plant that covered a
couple of acres employed 70 people and
one of the interesting things about is
he could not raise a cent of credit from
the Detroit banks Detroit financier
thought that making motor cars was a
folly you say that in 1919 123,000 990
motor vehicles were on the roads which
dates sorry 1919 no 1919 there were six
and a half million
I must have there wrong whatever it is a
hundred and thirteen thousand that would
have been twenty three thousand one
twenty three thousand that would that
would have been about 1908 to 1910 the
1900 figure you have is four 1192 yeah a
couple of thousand curved old olds
curved dashes the first American vehicle
that was sold commercially was made in
1893 in Chicopee Falls Massachusetts by
the brothers Frank and Charles de Raya
and by 1900 Ford had made a car or two
Ford Model motor company was
incorporated in 1903 after a couple of
false starts and these guys were
tinkerers
you know no one took them very seriously
they're made these noisy smelly things
that frightened the horses didn't go
very fast weren't too reliable nasty
propensity to blow up on you and there
were toys
really they were eccentric rickety and
it just goes woman in in a handful of
years from guys making these strange
machines in kind of corner shacks on
back alleys to within a decade
industrial palaces like no one had ever
seen one of the things about them was
they had acres of glass so that the
workers actually had light to work in
and they had canteens and Henry Ford in
1914 announced that he was going to pay
his stuff $5 a day for an eight-hour day
which was twice the average wage at that
time and not for the first time or the
last everybody said that Henry Ford was
quite mad but in fact of course he
remained the leading automaker for
another 13 years go back to Henry joy he
did what in regard to this night well he
bought the Packard company from the
original man Packard in Ohio built up
this huge firm the look the largest
luxury car maker in the world and he
test drove his vehicles himself he said
you know I will not be happy selling a
vehicle that I'm not happy driving and
he was long accustomed to taking these
vehicles out on extremely arduous test
trips into the Rockies the first Packard
26 in 1915 he drove it from Detroit to
San Francisco in three weeks through
cloying gumbo because it was a
horrendously wet spring and in 1913 a
man called Carl Fisher had come to him
Fisher was an Indianapolis car dealer
who once flew over the city of
Indianapolis suspended from a balloon as
a promotional stunt and he'd come up
with this idea of a road across America
everybody thought he was crazy you
couldn't do it but he said a road across
America let's build it before were too
old to enjoy it and he wanted to go to
Detroit and round up the car makers
behind this idea and he went to you
Henry joy and said joy the way we are
going about
at the moment we will have an American
highway system about the year 2000 and
between them they started this thing
called the Lincoln Highway Association
Fisher named the road Joe was the guy
who did the most work to promote it what
year the location was founded in 1913
and they'd made a lot of progress in in
turn them and they were fantastic
boosters these guys and then made a lot
of progress in implanting the idea of
the Lincoln Highway intend to the minds
of the American people it was it was
without any doubt the most famous road
in the world but they remained that
problem with it that it wasn't paved you
said that Carl Fisher also started
Indianapolis 500 he did he with some
three colleagues he built the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway and he paved
it in brick which was a fairly
innovative thing to do
he was I mean both of these guys and a
lot of the others that were involved
with them were amazing men just
incredibly energetic amazingly you know
visionary abundant abundant you know she
well Aviva in the case of Henry join us
it's a lovely story about Henry joy
driving back from New York to Detroit in
a early 1914 and the will hits a hole in
the road which happened all the time in
those days and he puts his head through
the windscreen and he needs minor
surgery so he has the operation and then
he telegrams his wife and bald-headed
hurrah do not have to work joy
realistically the likelihood of Henry
joy not working is about the same as the
Sun not coming up in the morning but
because he had so much on the go all the
time that guy we used to have a
congressman in this town by the name of
John Seiberling we pronounce it
Seiberling in the United from Ohio I
suspect he is a relative somewhere along
the way of this man whose name mr.
Birling may well be a will call okay
Frank Seiberling sibling is what I've
always called him what is he who is he
he's the president of Goodyear Tire and
Rubber and another of these great guys
who were behind the Lincoln Highway and
who were behind the convoy in 1919 he it
was a dabbler in all kinds of things he
didn't get going big time until quite
late I think he was in his late 30s
he'd lost a bunch of money you know
stock market panic and he somehow
managed to put together some little
deals with some friends to buy up a
bankrupt boarding company they've made
some sort of board and he bought it in
about 1898 and he was thinking he'd just
go back and carry on making this this
straw board stuff I guess for the
construction industry and - friend said
to him go into rubber Frank it is alive
and rubber itself you know as a viable
thing that the process of vulcanization
had been discovered by Goodyear the
inventor the rather calamitous
disorganized inventor some years earlier
but there wasn't any money in it of
course until the car came along and sure
enough Frank Seiberling starts up this
rubber foam and I think their first
order was twenty one dollars and 70
cents for little rubber caps to go on
medicinal bottles and he skated on thin
ice for a little while and then he got
an order to put tires on Model T's and
took off and became the largest tire
maker in the United States how many of
the 81 vehicles on this 1919 trip had
Goodyear tires on I couldn't tell you
that
Goodyear had just started promoting the
idea of pneumatic tires which none of
the army trucks at that time had they
had solid tires which would have been
made by Goodyear by Firestone by us
rubber but these solid tires must have
been awful to drive on on a good road
never mind a bad road I mean if you get
going any faster than 10 miles an hour
it would be only you could do to hang
onto the wheel and not get flung from
the cab because the vibration would be
so awful
speaking of army vehicles you say this
vehicle right here played a major role
on this trip yeah the millet or $40,000
of 1919 money that's some substantial
investment the US Army made there the
minotaur was considered the most
priceless asset
it basically towed just about every
other vehicle on the trip out of one
ditch one bug one swamp one mile one
quicksand morass after another and if
they'd not have had it they'd not have
got across it was a I think they called
it was it was a custom-designed
artillery wheeled tractor is what they
called it
I had a big iron Spragg on the back that
they could anchor down into into the
dirt and oftentimes they would be towing
vehicles out of the ditch or out of the
mess and the whole thing would just rear
up rear up pulling these other vehicles
out six of 81 vehicles didn't make it
uh-huh 61 days 1919 IAT and US 30 and
all its this Lincoln Highway still in
that area they still have a place you
can see the signs like different states
have done more or less good jobs in
remembering it Pennsylvania I think the
u.s. 30 corridor that if most of the
u.s. 30 is pretty much marked clear
across the state as a historic highway
and that continues as I say more or less
well in different states I remembered in
although Iowa Illinois you drive along
and you see us 30 whichever Road it
might be that at the time corresponds
still has Lincoln Highway on it there
are many places where the road is still
called Lincoln Highway which is nice to
see and that extends even out to a
little County Road in the desert in Utah
that's called the Lincoln Highway how
many miles would there go each day in
his convoy I think the longest trip
would have been somewhere around 90 days
at ninety miles in a day more often it
would be 50 odd you say that Mamie
Eisenhower hooked up with her husband
she was in Denver yeah maybe his family
had moved to Denver from Boone Iowa when
her father sold up their business in
Iowa and became a millionaire and she
had spent a lot of time there because
there were no married quarters at the
different camps that Ike was out here
over in the east so I don't think he'd
seen her for about eight months and
mamie's father had a map and he kept
pins on it showing the comte the
progress of the convoy and he'd been
trying all that spring of 1919 to stir
up enthusiasm in the family for a car
trip because it was you know as a big
adventure taking a car trip any
now that the convoy and I along with it
we're approaching he succeeded and
getting mainly to jump in the car with
him and they drive I think it would have
been about 200 miles from Denver to
North Platte Nebraska took them for 13
hours rarely got above second gear and
so she got all excited and that bog
referred describes are wearing this new
black lacy thing and she's bobbing in
and out of the hotel doorway looking
down the street and Conroy's had this
terrible day and their lumbering into
the town in bits and pieces and people
are stuck in mud and all over and
suddenly here comes this officers car
and their psyche hollering like a kid
there is how often on the trip did now
this is a Packard I think this is from a
19-15 tree how often did it look like
this in western Nebraska all too often
all too often they were fortunate it
could have been like that all the way
across Iowa luckily in Iowa it didn't
rainbow in western Nebraska there was
one stretch where it took them seven
hours and 20 minutes to go 200 yards
they were they were about the business
of saying we need to build plate roads
they did prove the need for it Colonel
McClure is mentioned throughout the
entire book who was he the clue was a
professional army officer who his father
was in the army he was from Carlinville
Illinois and he signed on 1905 if I
remember correctly and he'd been in the
Army 14 years he had seen service in the
Philippines he'd seen service in Mexico
he was back from Europe literally fresh
off the boat three or four days before
the convoy started and the convoy was in
a state of some ill discipline in
Washington and the motor transport
coordinate and it had been prepared by
an officer named captain Bernard McMahon
from Salinas in California and the men
loved him but maybe that was the problem
that he wasn't strict enough and they
the amount transport Corps put in
McClure over the man's head to try and
instill some discipline because
otherwise they weren't going to make
they weren't going to get there and they
were reported effectively a disorganized
rabble and they set off I said that
a lot of the men in dealing with their
vehicles exhibited language more in
keeping with a team of horses than the
internal combustion engine where is the
biggest crowd on the trip
the biggest crowd ful difficult one or a
big crowd there were many big crowds
Pittsburgh Salt Lake City
probably San Francisco I mean probably
the welcome in San Francisco and Oakland
would have been the hugest that the the
the welcome into Oakland was sensational
there were fireworks that special
fireworks made that when they went up
and blow up all the flags of all the
Allied nations came down fluttering out
of the fireworks and that the street was
lined with vehicles for miles
how big a deal was this back then when
you went through the do you go through
the newspapers oh yeah I went I read I
read the newspapers all the way across
this because these guys were front-page
news all the way across the country
pictures oh yeah oh yeah
controversies verbage yes many
controversies because the towns that
were on the route fought tooth and nail
to stay on the route and the towns that
were not on the route fought tooth and
nail to get other towns kicked off and
the route re-designated to them why and
how important was because if you had
pavement you were the future if you
stayed with a mud road you were not
going to get the traffic and you were
gonna die a commercial death in the mud
who got pavement because of this trip a
town in the United States that we know
today that wouldn't have been anything
if it hadn't gone through there if you
look at Cedar Rapids Iowa there's a
little town called Marion about five
miles five ten miles to the northeast
which was originally the county seat of
I think it's Linn County there in Iowa
seen a rapid American that and the
Lincoln Highway went on that a little
jog through Marion and then down into
Cedar Rapids because Marion was the
county seat Cedar Rapids being bigger
than Marion laid a fait accompli of
improved Road do you so that the traffic
would come due east avoiding Marion and
in Cedar Rapids within a couple of years
Marion was no longer the county seat
Cedar Rapids was Cedar
it's had the pavement Cedar Rapids had
the power cost of this to the federal
taxpayer there's just this 61 day trip
that I couldn't tell him what I can tell
you is that the first exercise in
federal funding for rogue building was
an act that passed in 1916 and it
allowed something like 15 million
dollars a year and it was a poor piece
of lawmaking because it had no national
plan built into it there was nothing
systematic about it so it was a
opportunity for pork barrel boondoggle
politics people are building little bits
of road here and there all over the
place but as a result of this trip in
1921 a Highway Act was passed that
committed the federal government to
spending seventy five million dollars a
year and over a period of five years
seventy five million dollars for each of
five years and it was the first time
that the government had said we need a
federally recognized national highway
system and this was really directly
attributable to the kind of massive
promotional boost that the convoy had
given to it so I can't tell you what the
convoy cost you say the War Department
evidently felt it was a sufficiently
worthwhile exercise because they sent
another one the next year and I don't
actually know what happened to that one
because the War Department report for
1920 was printed about three what weeks
after it had set off and rather than
going on the Lincoln Highway Route is
added in 1919 they tried to go on
another highway that was a later
invention it was called the Bankhead
highway they went down through the south
and the guy writing that the report said
well we've sent them off and it's taken
them 16 days just to get to Atlanta and
we figure they might get to LA in two or
three months they didn't know the rights
of so bad you said it - soldiers along
the way got married yeah - okay that's a
great story and he was called private
fred Golic in Chicago Heights Illinois
and the local papers all thought that
he'd met the girl the dance honors they
had a rest day on the Sunday so on a
Saturday evening there was a dance and
the local papers all thought that God
had met this girl
and the next day he Woo's her until his
past runs out with a passion goes back
to camp
gets up the next morning rushes off
finds her she agree he's a guy jumps on
a motorbike and rushes off to find
someone who'll marry them and someone or
less you a certificate and a sharp eared
reporter from one of Chicago papers
didn't believe this love at first sight
story and he overheard cun on the pier
saying to private garlic come isn't that
there's a bit hasty you know you've only
known her a matter of hours and private
Golic says no I've known her since
Tuesday we met in Bucyrus Ohio that's
okay you've known her for five days and
he said that the ride she would follow
him on the train all the way to LA where
he lived and that would be the honeymoon
we have some more video that was taken
by the army back in 1919 on this trip
well from what you saw on your own trip
what kind of I mean along the way how
many towns are just decrepit or how many
places did you go into and they'd there
are old hotels that were boarded up one
of the sad things that you see now is
that the hotels that used to be real
institutions in in in downtown
small-town America are either not there
or they're basically flat pounding and
wrecks and you know everybody's in a
motel out on the edge of town and that's
a natural development of what these guys
started but they didn't know it at the
time so for instance there's a little
town called Kimble out in western
Nebraska where there's this lovely
lovely building called the wheat growers
hotel and it's it's by the rail track
and if it could if the money could be
found to restore it it would be a
beautiful building and the officers had
a dinner that was laid on for them by
the local people in that hotel and you
can stand outside it in that white heat
of the Nebraska Sun and you can imagine
them all sad about having a nice dinner
and speaking about how this convoy was
going to change everything and how the
road was going to be paved because you
know at that time there was probably
only
a handful of motivic was in the whole
county out there what was that they
didn't foresee that paving the road was
gonna make towns spread out like this
there was another town in Nebraska
Lexington where they'd put up a
three-story bank and they'd left one
side of the building brick because they
figured that other buildings would go up
alongside it but of course as soon as
pavement came the town spread out up and
the new businesses with the garages and
the motels fanning out alongside the
highway as it went by the town you point
out that this was right at the end of
the World War one
and Dwight Eisenhower although he didn't
go overseas fought in that war
he didn't go overseas he trained other
men to do so but the second thing you
point out is the flu of eighteen of 1918
yeah I actually wrote a book about that
a couple of years ago but called the
devil's flu that was a truly calamitous
event something like 40 million people
died worldwide in the course of a year
and at least half a million Americans
died so there were really two
catastrophic events that came hard on
each other you had America joining the
war which resulted in the death of some
fifty thousand American soldiers and ten
times as many Americans dying at the
same time of this dreadful dreadful
pandemic so I think one of the nice
things about the convoy it just was a
feel-good factor you know that people
had been through a lot there was a lot
of strife a lot of grieving it was it
was a very difficult time I think race
relations were horribly strained they
were appalling race riots in Chicago in
Washington even well the convoy was on
the road and there any black soldiers
not on the convoy any racial events
along the way there there's a lot of
interesting stories about Omaha where
the mayor was very nearly lynched in the
process of a mob taking a black guy out
of the prison the way he'd been accused
of raping a white woman he was a pretty
unlikely suspect because he had pretty
bad arthritis
they took him out and strung in that and
they thought they might have a go at the
mayor while they were at it that
happened just after the convoy had been
through and that radicalized the black
community in Omaha considerably and one
of the leaders of the community after
that was a guy called Earl little his
son changed his name to X when we see
these vehicles moving down the road back
in 1919 on the screen what speed are
they going at five miles an hour if
they're lucky as I say a lot of the
trucks have solid tires so if you go
faster than ten you're gonna be thrown
out of the vehicle by the shuttering in
the juddering what's that the caddies
and the tractor yeah I think that would
have been the whole tractor the
caterpillar tractor yep they took a
caterpillar tractor with them that was
the other vehicle with the Minotaur that
helped tow them all through you know the
staff cars could get up to 60 miles an
hour the best of them and the Indians
and the Harley's the motorbikes that the
scouts used obviously they could tear
off about the landscape provided that
the engines didn't clogged with dust and
silt but the trucks five miles an hour
if you get onto a good paved road with
them ten you know they were they were
champing at the bit when they got to
California they viewed California as the
Promised Land because they had pavement
you know they'd been 2,000 miles without
seeing pavement and suddenly they come
out of Placerville towards Sacramento
and the road is lined with fruit tree
orchards you know the populace showered
troops with fruit that reported
lieutenant Jackson and you could just
see you can see from his telegram bliss
we've arrived on pavement after 2,000
miles of really hard work and it was the
Promised Land it was the land of the
future at the most advanced highway
system and these guys were driving on
that and the drivers were just checking
because McLaren said to them you will
still stick to the speed limit and they
really didn't want to California had to
be California was the scene of the first
arrest of the motorists by an airplane
first arrests of speeding motorists by
an airplane
I loved that image I just yeah this
guy's going down the road at 60 miles an
hour and the motorbike cop is chasing
him and his motorbike starts playing up
so he prices an aviation steel scoots in
there gets a pilot come on let's get him
and jump in the plane guy lands on the
road in front of him the speeding
motorists naturally think so he must be
in trouble so he gets certain he gets
arrested what did you do with your
chevrolet caprice 1985 model when he got
to San Francisco oh I missed that car I
sold it the parking valet in my hotel in
San Francisco for $800 why don't we do
that yep
sold it for 800 was sad to be rid of it
I hope the guy that I sold it to gets as
good a deal as I did along the way what
are the most memorable spots for you too
many to mention them all the 180 miles
of west central utah desert we mentioned
that was gorgeous I love that moment
when you're in central Nebraska and you
cross the hundreds Meridian and you feel
not just actually but mythically and
psychologically you feel that the West
is beginning but eastern Nebraska you
have that sense of vastness that
cornfields the size of Belgium and those
those amazing irrigation things just
spraying rainbow alter the horizon and
as you go along it's about the town of
Cozad I think you could feel the
landscape drying out and you can feel
the air thinning and you're slowly
rising and the grain elevators start
being replaced by stockyards at each
little town and each little town gets
further apart and the land starts to
buckle and get dry and then you get up
into Wyoming and it's just majestic
absolutely majestic I loved all that
there were towns in Iowa that I really
liked Jefferson in western Iowa as I
said I followed the route as closely as
a canon that meant down to county roads
I mean us 30 a lot of the way you can
stick to that and it's more or less than
thinking highway but there are people
who know about this stuff along the
route who have actually looked and said
well out here it was County Road e38
or whatever it might be and just by
Jefferson Iowa you can find a field and
the owner of that field in late teens
early 20s was a farmer
member of the Lincoln Highway
Association who wrote a letter to
Detroit with his Jews and said proud to
be a member of this you know this road
is going to be one of the great
achievements of our civilization here
and my $5 was a soldier at mission point
lost a foot lucky to be alive looking
forward to seeing this thing get built
and he put up two busts of Lincoln on
little plinths by that corner of his
field and over the years they got
vandalized and people forgot why they
were there but bless him there's some
good local people there who've got new
buffs made in their back and you can
drive by and see them and that's really
nice Classic Car Museum where's that
Canton Ohio yeah that's that's a good
one that's a good one very funny big big
sign there saying um please don't touch
the cars Bob shoots every tenth touch
and the ninth just left Studebaker
that's that's another really interesting
story I'll tell you one of the most
memorable things it's a sad thing but
but Studebaker was this amazing
industrial story in South Bend Indiana
and packard lost its way after World War
two and the last Packard came off the
production line in 1956 and Studebaker
took them over moved production to
Indiana so if that's 56 so that's half a
century ago
you can go to Detroit today that plant
is still there it's this huge industrial
ruin and you think about everything that
Henry joy did in his life and everything
that he built and now it's just a
million broken windows
wasn't there a car caught with Henry
Johnny something like that age I don't
know that I couldn't tell you but I just
remember you talking about you know
resonant moments there are a lot of
happy moments a lot of amazing
achievements in this book but it was sad
to look at that
incredible building it still got Packard
1907 written on the lintel but I'll tell
you another thing and this is a nice
story this is a cheering story in the
same way that the Packard plants just
been left to go like that
Henry joy died in 36 37 and his wife put
up
in the best possible place she's putting
on the Continental Divide in the middle
of nowhere in Wyoming this is absolutely
appropriate to this guy because he loved
to get in his car and go out and camp
and cook bacon on a fire in the morning
and this monument went up in I think 38
39 and it was a simple black obelisk
surrounded by a little railing
they had a Lincoln Highway marker post
on each of the four corners and it was a
great place to set it because it was
very appropriate to him and what he
loved to do but of course nobody knew
that it was there and in I guess it
would have been June you know June July
towards you know two-thirds of the way
through the trip I found it there
there's no guidebook that said it was
there and it was very resonant again to
stand in that majestic landscape by this
monument to this guy who more than any
other one individual person did so much
for that for the getting going of the
building of roadways in this country and
there was nobody knew about it and again
happy ending good local people in
conjunction with the Department of
Transportation and where I mean moved
that Monument and they've put it at a
rest stop on the interstate at the top
of telephone Canyon and I think he gets
his place in history back for that how
often did you find pictures like this
one where soldiers are wiped out they
must have been so tired they must have
been so tired that's a great collection
of them in Abilene and there are two
other great collections in an hour yeah
and there are good collections in Ann
Arbor as well that is the Iowa
Department of Transportation came up
with that one that's a gem of a bridge
against Taylor Iowa there is another
Bridget somewhat akin to that somewhere
in Nevada and I've never been able to
track it down where it is but that's now
on the National Register of Historic
Places the one that says Lincoln Highway
on either side here's Colonel McClure
where is this structure from Salt Lake
City yes the fair maidens of Salt Lake
presented him with a floral truck which
he duly said that he was enormously
honored and then he would take it with
him to San Francisco
I rather doubt he kept that promise
somehow any careers made in the military
after this or even in politics in the
military oddly no most of them I think
very tellingly
seem to have quit the army immediately
after the convoy had gone off to Detroit
to work for the car industry McClure had
been 14 years in the army went straight
off to Detroit and went to work for
Packard and I think that probably tells
us a lot about who had the real clout
behind this expedition ironically
Packard stop making trucks in 1923
because didn't chime with their image as
luxury carmakers but prior to that they
had been well at the end of World War
one the US Army had 80,000 trucks and
packard claimed that one in five of them
was a packard now did you pick up any
new ideas about another book about the
United States while you made this trip
yah-hoo several it's such a joy to come
to this country because you you feel
that that's just this inexhaustible fund
of stories yeah this wonderful variety
this infinitely magnificent landscape oh
there we go even look like Prairie skin
that's know they even look like Prairie
skin isn't as I said early on it's just
a miracle that nobody died and you see
them on those mountain trails in the
West there are places though you know
the precipitous drops sometimes of
hundreds in in the Sierra Nevada a
thousand feet and the whales are is
close from the edge they didn't lose one
truck over a mountainside in
Pennsylvania but I suppose the thing
about it is given the trucks probably
not going fast in two or three miles an
hour and there is no cat lucky to get on
road like this good roads movement what
this whole thing was gone that was one
aspect of it the good roads movement
began with people riding bicycles when
Dunlop in Northern Ireland invented the
pneumatic tire everybody could go out
and ride a bicycle in comfort the League
of American Willman they were called but
a lot of wheel women as well so what's
that book gonna be that you found on
this trip
can I keep that to myself can you give
us here there there is a bunch of
stories and I haven't decided which one
yet so no so of all the things you've
done all the places you've gone the
other wonders of the world that you've
seen where did would you put this on the
list very high it's in the top five why
it was I it was a great piece of
research to do I felt like by the time
I'd gained I was getting to the end of
the trail but I was actually living in
my mind in 1919 because I was reading
all the stories and watching them
develop through through the course of
the convoy one of the things about
reading the papers were I didn't just
want to set I didn't just want to tell
the story of here's a convoy they drive
across America I wanted to set it in the
context of the time and the issues that
people were concerned about so as a
piece of research that was a really
joyous joyous job to do and I loved
doing it I loved you know looking at the
baseball scores and looking at the the
stories that people were concerned about
where there was a big scandal at the
time really wicked Parisian fashions
were creeping in and women were going
about the place without stockings on and
defenders of the public morals were
rushing off to parks and bathing places
checking up on the length of bathing
costumes because of these tremendously
corrupting European ideas all those
little details I loved doing all that
but you know as an experience I'm not
sure how many Europeans are really aware
of how just fabulously hospitable this
country can be and if you spend a few
months here which I've done on several
occasions write in different books
it just becomes it's just become as a
real pleasure to travel about small town
America the cities whichever but to
travel through and meet people and find
out the histories of these little towns
that's justice to treat so it's it's
it's high on the list I'll be back
we're out of time and here's the cover
of the book our guest has been West
Yorkshire England native Pete Davies the
book is American Road from the 1919
convoy across you know
States thank you very much for joining
us thank you pleasure